thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies the surface of
this basketball is 2-dimensional and
it's easy to see it's curved from our
very three-dimensional point of view but
what if we were tiny 2 dimensional
beings living on the surface how would
we be able to tell it was curved and
once we know how are we going to explain
it to anyone else this episode was made
possible by generous supporters on
patreon we're gonna cover some pretty
heavy stuff today but I think you can
handle it as long as we put it in the
right context let's start with
perception we might live in three
dimensions but we don't actually see in
three dimensions the only reason we see
anything is because light enters our
eyes that light doesn't carry distance
information though it creates a
2-dimensional image on the retina
yes two-dimensional we just happen to
have two eyes which means we get two
two-dimensional images this is what your
eyes send to your brain as you walk
around there are two images offset by
the distance between your eyes
we call it parallax the reason you
altima Leone Lisi one image in your mind
is because your brain is doing a lot of
processing first it overlays the images
and looks for differences the bigger the
difference the closer that thing is that
plus lighting shadows and prior
knowledge of object sizes all allow the
brain to imagine depth knowing this
though we can trick the brain this is a
2-dimensional image of a cube your
screen is 2d so the image is 2d it only
looks 3d because of artificial lighting
and shadows if I flatten the light the
illusion mostly disappears but if you've
got a pair of these we can make the 3d
effect even more dramatic this is called
a stereoscopic image one image is red
and the other a cyan each color filter
blocks one of the images and it makes
the cube look almost tangible so we see
in two dimensions and imagine in 3d
actually we live in a four-dimensional
space-time
right and therein lies our problem that
fourth dimension can be difficult for us
to imagine since it's time we might be
tempted to picture a clock attached to
axes or something but it's a lot more
useful to picture that time dimension as
if it's a space dimension that's where
we get things like space-time diagrams
we've seen in previous videos how
powerful those can be unfortunately to
draw those we need to suppress the space
dimensions at most we can draw two of
the three because the third dimension is
taken up by time it's impossible to draw
four perpendicular axes in a three
dimensional picture and we can't draw
four dimensional pictures so what do we
do well we can avoid pictures altogether
and just do math yeah yeah I know that's
not very satisfying the only other
option is to try and get the most out of
a diagram like this and the best way to
do that is to imagine what it's like to
be a lower dimensional being let's see
what one dimension is like this is line
land the only directions are forward and
backward any beings living in this space
have only one dimension a length from
their point of view though things look a
little different remember we live in 3d
and C and 2d site is always one
dimension down these creatures live in
one dimension so they see in zero
dimensions their world looks something
like this to them since light has no
room to spread out it's always the same
brightness so what they're looking at
never changes it makes the entire
concept of sight kind of useless so they
probably never evolved it to begin with
there's also no room for them to move
around each other so they can either
live comfortably in the length they have
or they can eat each other dude sorry
that was a little dark sorry let's say
with our omnipotent powers we pop one of
these beings out of line land there now
free to move around in two dimensions
and perceive their one dimensional world
from the outside with whatever senses
they have assuming they could understand
what was happening which they probably
couldn't how would they explain it to
another being in line land
if Wineland was actually a giant circle
with these one-dimensional beings be
able to measure that curvature from the
inside no see one dimensional space is
like circles only have extrinsic
curvature that's curvature we can only
see if we're looking from a higher
dimensional space like this two
dimensional space what 1 dimensional
spaces don't have is intrinsic curvature
that's curvature you can measure from
inside the space we could take every
point on the circle and map it to every
point on this flat line without any
distortion you just snip the circle and
flatten it out that means there's no
intrinsic curvature but our
four-dimensional space-time has
intrinsic curvature and it's the only
one we can measure from the inside so
one-dimensional spaces aren't gonna help
us let's try two dimensions this is
flatland any beings living here have a
link than a wiff but no thickness they
do have room to move around each other
so their behavior is a little more
familiar from our point of view we can
actually see inside their bodies from
their point of view things look a little
different they live in two dimensions so
they see in one dimension this is what
they look like to each other
sight is a useful trait things would
look brighter and larger when they're
closer and they would look dimmer and
smaller when they're farther away having
two eyes would have the same benefit to
them that it does to us
they could even infer two-dimensional
shape from that information if a square
in a triangle are looking at each other
they'd see the difference this seems a
lot like our own universe in our own
experience
maybe curvature is similar to if
flatland was actually the surface of a
giant sphere with two dimensional beings
be able to measure that curvature from
the inside
yes actually all they have to do is
measure something called the Riemann
curvature which has to do with how the
space maps onto the flattest possible
space remember in the one dimensional
case how we could map this circle onto a
flat line all we had to do was snip the
circle and flatten it
there was no distortion we can do
similar maps in two dimensions
sometimes there's Distortion the Riemann
curvature tells us how much distortion
there would be if you take a flat 2d
space and bend it into a cylinder
there's no distortion in the grid
distance measurement still makes sense
all parallel lines stay parallel the
cylinder has zero intrinsic curvature
which means zero Riemann curvature wait
what how can it have zero román
curvature its riemann not Roman and
don't forget there are two types of
curvature any curvature you're seeing
here is only because the 2d surface is
embedded in a 3d space it's not
intrinsic to the 2d surface it's
extrinsic to the 3d space anyway a
cylindrical space doesn't have intrinsic
curvature if you're living in one of
these two spaces but you can't tell the
difference but if the space is something
like a torus or a sphere
there's definitely intrinsic curvature
you could tell the difference we'll be
using the sphere for the rest of the
video because well it's easier to
understand than a torus the Riemann
curvature is a tensor in two-dimensional
space each of the four indices can take
on two possible values x and y or theta
and fee or 1 and 2 or whatever you
decided to call your axes that means the
curvature tensor has 2 to the 4 or 16
components for a spherical surface
though 12 of them are 0 the other 4 are
the same plus or minus 1 over R squared
everywhere on the surface out of 16
total components there's really only one
independent nonzero component that R is
the radius of the sphere which the two
dimensional beings wouldn't be able to
see but one of them could measure the
Riemann curvature and infer it um how
parallel transport come on doesn't
everyone get excited about parallel
transport I know I do anyway let's
imagine we're all tiny beings moving
around on the surface of a giant sphere
oh I guess we don't have to imagine that
hard do we when we're standing on the
surface of the earth
looks pretty flat but that's because
we're only seeing a tiny fraction of its
surface area about point zero zero zero
zero one percent of it that two
dimensional being might have a similar
problem in their two-dimensional space
they think their space is flat but then
we use our um nipa today our Stu pop one
of them out there now free to move
around in three dimensions and look down
at flatland to their surprise they see
that it's curved now they know their
space isn't actually flat but if we put
them back in they're gonna want to tell
their friends unfortunately their
friends are ignorant of this fact
because they lack the three-dimensional
experience this is where parallel
transport comes in say they map out a
closed path like this triangle for
example and they pick a vector to carry
around with them like their initial
velocity leaving copies of it behind for
reference they walk around the path with
their vector with every step they take
they make sure to keep their vector
parallel to the vector they left behind
in the previous step that's why we call
it parallel transport they continue
until they return to their original
starting point that's when they check
the vector they've been transporting
against the one they left behind if the
vectors are at an angle to each other
the space is curved if they're not at an
angle this does not prove the space is
flat it might just be that their path
was too small they could use a bigger
path and try again or they could just go
around the smaller path a bunch of times
until the angle accumulates either way
if they find an angle it proves the
space is curved what does this have to
do with Raymond's curvature anyway it's
Riemann curvature what does this have to
do with Riemann curvature everything
those little parallel transports are
represented by something called the
Christoffel symbols and those determine
the Riemann curvature tensor a tensor
that has one independent nonzero
component in two dimensions six
independent nonzero components in three
dimensions and 20 independent nonzero
components in four dimensions we may
never truly understand what it means to
be three-dimensional being in a
four-dimensional space-time but we can
imagine one dimensional beings in a two
dimensional space-time or even two
dimensional beings in a three
dimensional space
lower dimensions are definitely
something we have a handle on they can
give us a rough idea of issues we may
run into trying to measure curvature on
our own universe as long as we can
parallel transport vectors around our
own space-time we can ultimately find
the Riemann curvature of that space-time
that's a big deal because you'll find
contracted versions of that tensor in
Einstein's equation the equation that
tells us gravity is curvature if you
don't understand how curvature works
then understanding gravity is kind of
hopeless so if you have any questions
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
brilliant is a problem-solving based
website and app with a hands-on approach
with over 60 interactive courses in math
science and computer science try adding
some learning structure to your day by
setting a goal to improve yourself and
then work at that goal just a little bit
every day oliver ilion's courses have
storytelling code writing interactive
challenges and problems to solve if you
watch this video you clearly like to
challenge yourself you could try
brilliants course on vector calculus
where you'll learn about important
vectors in three-dimensional space that
tell us a lot about the curvature of
paths you can also keep your mind
stimulated with their daily challenges
brilliant puzzles you surprises you and
expands your understanding of the modern
world if this sounds like a service
you'd like to use go to brilliant org
slash science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20% off an annual
subscription to everyone asking if
space-time has a breaking point no it
doesn't on Stein's equation is always
proportional even inside the event
horizon of a black hole anyway thanks
for watching